what is tougher what is tougher to do
and what is more worthier to do in your
opinion okay
um
I'm in high school I get out of high
school I'm ambitious okay
is it tougher to be
a person who
is at the level of intelligence to get
22 honorary doctorates you know these
Awards etc etc knowing all of these
different topics being well read Etc so
from zero to that is it tougher to be a
billionaire is it tougher to become the
best athlete in the world like a Tom
Brady is it tougher to make it to the
highest level as an actor where you're
like a you know Daniel Day-Lewis or at
that level type of a person what's
tougher or are all of them independent
to the individual
so it's that's a mathematically solvable
problem you ask how many people are at
that level and how many people are
trying to be at that level divide the
two numbers interesting and there you
have it yeah so it is tougher to be an
MBA star than it is to be a medical
professional a medical doctor it's
tougher statistics it's just statistics
right you can just do pure statistics
and but that alone should not stop you
because what you'd then be saying to
yourself is
I have these two roots and I'm more
likely to succeed here than there so I'm
not gonna go where my true love is
because I will probably not succeed well
that you've already kind of surrendered
didn't you and I would say that
you know I used I used to wrestle you
know you don't choose wrestling because
it's easy you choose wrestling because
it's hard
Kennedy said that about our space
program we choose to go to the Moon not
because it's easy but because it's hard
I can tell you this by trying most hard
things
even if you have to take an exit ramp
for having tried the hard thing you are
better off than having done something
easy
and anytime I ask I'm asking her advice
in school what classes should I take
what should I do I say take the hardest
possible classes you can
but then what about my GPA hey comes
again what about my GPA well okay you
can take an easy class and get a high
GPA that everyone will praise you for
for three months after graduation but
then because you took easy classes
everyone else
took the same easy class that's the
definition of easy isn't it and so you
will not distinguish yourself among
others who have been in school
so I've had people say I should know
this I had a 4.0 GPA no you should know
it because you studied it not because
you had a GPA that had anything to do
with it okay you should know because you
cared about it and you knew enough to
absorb it and remember it but apparently
you didn't because you only did it for
the exam so you're still peddling your
GPA about this so all I would say is
you're
uh oh which was that handsome guy right
there was that you as a wrestler what's
that all about yeah in high school
that's called College dude
I said the the sexiest astrophysics live
was clearly 50 pounds ago what
how much did you weigh then what did you
do in that instant 191 pounds oh you
were and you're six two six two six two
yeah you were yeah you were a monster
right there those biceps yeah I just
came off the mat and they said and the
guy was on the was like laying down on
the man took it so it's up at that angle
do you talk about this often because
I've never heard you address this that's
a chapter long gone I'm when I was when
I was wrestling when I was I also danced
when I was doing those things I no one
was publishing my books what kind of
dancing were you doing I was a
performing member of three different
dance companies
um but the college troops not the ball
shorts by the way I think he needs to
know as much as you kind of were joking
at one point he considered being an
exotic dancer I think I've read it yeah
well because I was in graduate school
and there wasn't you're not paid very
much as a teaching assistant and I
thought you were like you read up on it
or not no no and so uh with my fellow
dancers from the dance look at this guy
right here I was
um I was in desperate need of money and
I had any money and he said hey we we in
the evenings we dance at this uh male
dancer review and women put money in
your in your in your in your jock strap
and I so I said he said why don't you
come down take a look so I went down
this would be a way to make money back
then I was physically fit and I could do
a full split and I was I was graceful
and strong strong and Nimble so I I
totally could have rocked whatever and
was necessary for that I'm thinking so I
go there
and they come they come out with
asbestos line jock straps
that had been infused with lighter fluid
and ignited
and they came out dancing to Jerry Lee
Lewis's Great Balls of Fire and in that
instant I said hmm I think I'll be a
math tutor and I'm I'm deeply
embarrassed and disappointed with myself
that math tutor was not the first thing
that came to my head that I took the
options though considered
on fire for me wow mind blowing it took
me nuts on fire for me to be to be
slapped back into reality so I tutored
math in physics I thought you were going
to blow my mind with some
astrophysicists asked me about
astrophysics yet okay by the way what
was your your stage name at the time
no I I didn't have it today I feel like
I would have had a great stage name for
you well what what the black hole oh
yeah no yeah no no no no
right there was a better name right yeah
Dark Matter
[Laughter]
Pat this is should be a great segue for
you to talk about it I'm not doing it
because it's dark matter the James Earl
Jones please help us bring Dark Matter
yeah so so what was the point we were
making here about uh what's tougher to
do what's tough tougher to do you do it
because it's hard you don't do it
because you know what I thought the
other day
you're a sports guy I saw a guy making
an argument why the goat of goats isn't
Brady it's messy and the way the guy
broke it down is there's seven billion
people fighting to be eight billion
people fighting to be the best soccer
player and it's a World Sport and
football's only 330 million years pure
numbers yeah he kind of took the angle
you were taking yeah definitely do you
know how many billionaires there's in
America do you know the number at this
moment
um let me guess don't don't pull it up I
want to see what happens I'd like to
guess too let me guess
don't pull it up I want to see what
you're going to say as well I'm gonna
say
somewhere between
1 and 200. one in 200 what are you gonna
say I don't know I'm just thinking if I
do get this right somehow I'm going to
beat no grass I see not a smart one I'm
going with I'm going with I'm going with
195. 195.
so you guys think out of 330 million
people there's only 195 billionaires
yeah yeah 200 billion the number is uh
in the united states in the U.S I'm not
saying the world because I came into
that number because I've met like six of
them right and so nice little humble
bracket so given my given that and I'm
in New York City where a lot of
billionaires are yeah I'm just
extrapolating up and I'm thinking there
might be some states where no
billionaires live you know so click on
it let's see how many it says the number
I think is 740 or 900. what 740 there
you go in the united states in the
United States is 740. oh we were very
they live in 42 out of the 50 states
okay very wrong 740 yeah but that number
she is way higher than even just
recently right well no a lot of them
lost a lot of money this year so that's
an updated number because a lot of
people lost their status huh 2022 and
2020 yeah 2022 was not a good year for
billionaires so there's trillions a
thousand billionaires do you think
that's a big deal though do you for you
to say 100 to 200 do you think you said
that because you think it's hard to do
or do you think you said that because
why'd you say 100 to 200 I'm curious no
I extrapolated from the six that I know
that's okay there was no deep thought
involved yes based on those numbers yeah
yeah and I know seven seven billionaires
so it's just still not funny well he's
in Miami he parties with most of them
anyway so a lot of them are here okay no
no but but you say
I let me just push back on you a little
just
um emotionally push back please
if in life your goal is to be a
billionaire what kind of life is that I
think your goal in life should be
successful at some thing and if that
happens to bring a lot of money then
that's great because then you'd be
happier and I think life happiness
should play an important role and I
don't know how I got to be a billionaire
otherwise I'm not going to be happy and
then what will what will that force you
to do
what kind of decisions will you end up
making to achieve that goal relative to
just trying to be the best at something
that you can now maybe you want to be
the best at making money
okay good luck okay but it reminds me of
actors okay if people say I want to be a
famous actor really you don't want to be
a really good actor you don't want to be
a great actor
you just want to be a famous actor why
don't you be the best actor you can be
and let the fame follow that
then you'll get the famed organically
with you having been ambitious in your
trade yeah the reason why I asked the
questions I got four kids and we're
having a conversation yesterday about
football how old are they uh 10 9 6 18
months 10 9 6 6 18 months yes he do I
would have 20 more if I could but you
know we're shutting it down so anyways
we're having this conversation about the
nine-year-old yesterday did I hear
vasectomy there is that we're shutting
it down nothing yeah he's getting one
yeah so his beautiful wife yeah so I
understand so so the whole idea is if
we're going the route of uh uh if we're
going the route of you know what these
kids want to do in the conversation
yesterday was the youngest son
nine-year-old wants to play football my
sister's like well you know you sure you
want to put them in football with the
stats and all this other stuff we sat
down and went out of conversation with
the guy so listen with another seat with
a nine year old we showed him videos I
never read Antonio Brown here's what he
said here's what this person said here's
a clip watch this clip watch that Club
watches clip the kit still wants to play
football there it is so no matter how
much you push him away you're not going
to be able to force the kid to do what
you want him to do you could but you may
create reasons you don't push them away
you just expose them to information
exactly and of course when you're nine
especially your brain is not fully
rationalized yet so I would revisit it
every couple of years with your child
but your good kid could be the most
famous football player there ever was
and you don't want to be the one who
who interfered with that plus football
is slowly getting safer relative to
decades ago take a look at the the hits
that Terry Bradshaw took
uh he looks like why is he still alive
all right and and their laws were put
into place since then so I'm just saying
as a parent I think your goal should be
not to require they study or interested
in one thing or another but that they're
exposed to the the joys and the
sufferings of whatever it is they might
choose to do and then let them make
their own decision that would ensure
that it's a more organically arrived app
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]